et on continue avec la chronique
économique
alice rebond soir et présentez nous
votre invité est oui moi de la crémation
exactement la crémation me disais plus
généralement du marché des pompes
funèbres et puis de cette hausse des
demandes de crémations dans la france au
niveau national on fait le point avec
vous gérard jose bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de secteur dans les yvelines
pour le groupe ogf leader en europe et
dont font partie notamment les pompes
funèbres générales alors la demande de
crémation est en hausse on le disait en
+ 34 % rien que dans les yvelines soit
une hausse de 4% en un an c'est une
hausse que vous observez au quotidien
c'est une hausse qu'on observe au
quotidien alors il ya deux chiffres qui
vont nous éclairer en fin des années 70
dans les années 80 en france il y avait
neuf crématorium pour 4500 crémation
aujourd'hui en france vous avez 150
crématoriums et il y à 160000 crémation
en 2011 voilà pour situer un tout petit
peu donc
l'augmentation de la crémation en france
alors pour ce qui concerne les yvelines
effectivement ça situe aux environs de
30 4 35% effectivement nous avons
rencontré un de vos collaborateurs qui
qui travaille lui à versailles dans une
des agences des pompes funèbres
générales on regarde ce reportage ans
pour faire le point sur cette demande de
crémation nook est en hausse
c'est un phénomène qui est apparu il y a
quelques années de plus en plus de
français se tournent vers la crémation
selon un sondage ifop pour les pompes
funèbres générales la demande est
actuellement de 32% et devrait atteindre
50% d'ici une dizaine d'années
explications avec un professionnel du
métier devant les cavurnes du cimetière
des gones arts à versailles le coût des
obsèques crémation sont en moyenne sur
la région parisienne de 3500 euros et en
inhumation d'environ 4500 euros pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas encore
deux concessions
funéraire dans un cimetière pour des
pour des inhumations il faudra acquérir
cette concession faire un monument
funéraire donc ce qui va augmenter la
facture d'eau tant d'autres facteurs
expliquent cette hausse comme le manque
de place dans les cimetières en région
parisienne certaines personnes
considèrent aussi que la crémation est
plus écologique que l'inhumation une
demande de plus en plus difficiles à
satisfaire
compte tenu du manque de crématorium la
france en compte aujourd'hui 144 pour
plus de 160000 crémations par an il faut
effectivement que la france s'équipant
crématorium nous sommes un petit peu en
retard au niveau de ses équipements les
yvelines compte un seul crématorium
situé aux mureaux la construction d'un
tel édifice est à l'initiative des
communes sur appel d'offres auprès des
professionnels des pompes funèbres
par ailleurs la loi oblige les communes
de plus de 2000 habitants à disposer
d'un site cinéraire
gérard jose on l'entendait dans le sujet
un seul un crématorium existe dans les
yvelines il est aux mureaux donc les
personnes qui sont à versailles doivent
aller soit à clamart soit à nanterre est
ce que vous vous pouvez faire la demande
de créer des crématoriums
nous en tant qu'entreprise on ne peut
faire de demande en fait nous répondait
des appels d'offres la demande doit
venir des collectivités locales est ce
qu'il y ait une obligation selon la
taille des collectivités il n'y a aucune
obligation aucune obligation cellulaire
c'est la commune qui doit donc déclenché
ce souhait et qui a traversé un peu soit
le construire elle même soit demander à
des entreprises donc à gré comme nous de
le construire et à partir de là d'une
donnée une nous accorder une gestion tel
écran explique et un seul crématorium et
qui vont fournir aux en l'occurrence
pascal a forcément une demande il ya il
y a également valable pour les familles
d'aller dans un autre département
d'aller à nanterre c'est quand même pas
tous prêts oui il y à une demande si ce
n'est qu' il faut savoir que le
département des yvelines en l'occurrence
versailles les environs et un
départements et des communes avec des
communes très traditionaliste donc il
faut dire
que la crémation n'était pas n'était pas
trop à l'ordre du jour jusqu'à présent
par rapport à d'autres départements
financent par rapport à d'autres
départements d'autres communes d'autres
départements d'autres régions où la
crémation est quand même relativement
forte dans l'est de la france par
exemple c'est en commune mesure bon donc
sur les versailles les environs c'était
un peu c'était beaucoup plus discret
alors il se trouve que
nous avons aujourd'hui un seul
crématorium moi je le déplore parce que
avec l'augmentation de la crémation non
seulement l'état actuel et à 34 35 %
mais également ce qu'il va arriver parce
que 34 aujourd'hui mais c'est 50 demain
oui c'est ce qu'on voit l'art et dans
l'entente de fusil et par conséquent un
crématorium sur les yvelines ne suffira
pas seulement pas donc nous nous sommes
nous sommes en position d'attenté nous
sommes demandeurs de crématoriums par
rapport à l'ensemble des pays européens
et si un comparatif est ce qu'on est
plus mieux équipés que d'autres moins
bien équipés tenant rattraper un peu le
retard mais c'est sans commune mesure la
crémation en france des quelque chose
qu'on ne connaissait pas puisqu'elle a
réellement démarré en dans les années 70
elle a redémarré dans les années 70 de
façon tout à fait comme je le disais
tout à l'heure on peut en bulle tout à
fait tout à fait faible donc on a un
énorme retard à rattraper et ce retard
serait que se rattrape petit petit à
petit donc les pays du nord sont mes
équipes et à oui c'est une affaire qui
devrait justement pourquoi les pays du
nord du nord sont mieux équipés c'est
une question de religion aussi oui je
pense le pratique collège d'alma
monsieur jeu c'était très intéressante
dans des lieux comme les yvelines qui
sont plus traditionnelles et
traditionnelle bond se savoir plus
compliqué comme mais ça veut dire qu'il
ya quelque chose d'un souvenir d'une
expérience chrétienne qui tient beaucoup
au corps enfin le corps à une grande
place y compris le corps qui est mort en
fait le lien avec la terre enfin il ya
toute une symbolique la très forte
donc ce n'est pas très étonnant dans nos
lieux plus traditionnelles ce soit comme
ça ce n'est pas du tout le cas de
l'europe du nord qui est beaucoup plus
marquée par le protestantisme et par une
autre sensibilité au corps moi ça
m'étonne pas beaucoup ce que vous dites
ça c'est vraiment très typique de la
région versaillaise si on veut dire mais
par des rires ça y est je pense qu'il ya
de la mémoire d'une tradition chrétienne
sur la terre le corps etc et que le feu
ne remplace pas ça lorsqu'il peut aussi
motivé à la demande de crémation c'est
son prix on le voyait dans le reportage
en temps de crise économique de nouveaux
acteurs apparaissent sur le marché des
entreprises son entreprise low cost en
fête en proposant les services de base
obligatoire il arrive à des prix réduits
autour de 1500 euros parfois les prix
d'appel sont même en deçà est ce que ce
sont des concurrents sérieux pour vous
non est ce qu'il vous faut faire non une
ligne ne sont sérieux pour nous ils nous
font peur tout simplement tout
simplement nous ne sommes pas une samba
sur le même créneau voilà nous ne
resterons pas là nous ne recherchons pas
la même chose c'est-à-dire des biens
nous ne mettons pas le prix au centre de
préoccupations nous mettons le client et
les familles au centre de reculer le
défunt et les familles au centre de nos
préoccupations c'est à dire que au lieu
de partir parce que vous me parlez de
deux de ses sociétés low cost c'était
low cost vous parlez de 1500 euros c'est
même plus bas ces 800 euros mais des
prix d'appel de la pub là ils ont fait
qu'est ce que réellement on peut avoir
un service funéraire à 800 euros
aujourd'hui mais non c'est pas c'est pas
raisonnable donc le fait de multiples
services vont se rajouter au tour pour
monter jusqu'à au moins 1500 euros
écoutez
il est il a été prouvé que en partant de
800 euros comme c'est proposés avec des
prestations ils sont qui sont cachés
mais qu'il faut avoir parce que un prix
d'appel avec 100 sans porter je vois pas
comment vous pouvez faire un enterrement
sans porter donc il faut les compter les
porter et on part est ce que vous
observez dans les cimetières justement
des cérémonies low cost
j'ai le souvenir mais pas très récent
j'ai le souvenir de certains enterrement
dont on sentait bien que et du côté
porter et du compte et aurait respect
des horaires une certaine manière de se
comporter par rapport aux morts
j'accueille la famille était un peu un
peu rapide enfin on sentait qu'il y
avait quelque chose de low cost au
niveau pas du prix mais de la qualité
moi j'ai j'ai souvenir de ça un pas très
récent d'ailleurs mais j'ai souvenir de
sa wii simplement je voulais rebondir
sur ce que vous disiez le low cost nous
nous on sait pas faire mais on sait se
mettre à la portée de nos clients c'est
à dire que partant de là nous avons nous
écoutons ce que veut lyon nous écoutons
d'abord ce que la famille souhaite
rendre comment la famille souhaite
rendre hommage à leur défunt et à partir
de là on bâtit un devis une organisation
et nous savons faire parce que à travers
à travers des options et nous avons sept
nous pouvons proposer des objets des
désignations local nous à 1995 euros
voyez mais tout compris donc ça veut
dire quand même que ces entreprises
locaux sel vous pousse aussi peut-être
réduire vos marges du coup à dire
beaucoup parce que c'est vrai que ça
représente un coût pour les familles
c'est c'est lors je n'en parle
simplement c'est vrai qu'à toute la
douleur mais derrière la bulle or il ya
aussi un coup et quand on n'a pas
préparé c'est que je vais me contredire
je vous contredire parce que en fait on
est et on été les précurseurs
n'eut été les précurseurs alors que
c'est ce site et low cost sont
relativement récentes nous on le fait
depuis quelques années ces propositions
de tarifs
optionnel à travers un menu de 2009 195
euros c'est beaucoup plus tôt
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup gérard
jost pour votre éclairage à cette
dernière question sur les locations des
funérailles sur internet oui j'aimerais
vous avertit alors oui cette tendance le
cost est aussi lié non seulement la
crise économique mais aussi au
développement d'internet c'est à dire de
plus en plus de familles vont
directement chercher les services sur
internet et donc derrière il ya un coût
qui est moindre aussi oui la vente à l
avantage d'internet c'est que c'est un
service qui marchent l'intéressant sur
24 donc vous avez les personnes qui ont
besoin d'interroger de d'avoir quelques
renseignements sur les obsèques qui
peuvent à n'importe quelle heure pour se
rendre pour se renseigner alors
effectivement beaucoup de sociétés se
sont créés on ayant créé des services en
ligne
nous mêmes nous mêmes nous avons créé un
effet il a fait vous alignez aussi sur
la tendance oui on s'est alignée sur la
tendance mais encore une fois encore une
fois c'est pas pour tirer les prix comme
le font les soutes est low cost parce
que low cost internet ces low cost
marche uniquement à travers internet moi
j'ai lu chemise article dessus où on
disait oui finalement ce sont des les
familles n'ont pas de besoin et internet
bras internet ya pas de contact avec nos
commerciaux c'est très bien nous malgré
les prix qui peuvent être à travers donc
nos services en ligne des prix plus plus
plus simple nous conservons quand même
ce contact entre le client on se doute
que dans ces événements le contacter et
à 5 ans est essentielle merci à sonder
devenir en plateau mercialys on va
terminer la chronique sur le chômage
parce que la semaine dernière on avait
dit qu'on reviendra en détail sur ces
chiffres un conte a eu donc plus 1,6
pour cent en septembre on le voit sur ce
tableau au niveau national un nom plus
de trois millions de demandeurs d'emploi
dans les yvelines la situation n'est pas
bonne non plus avec cette hausse qui est
supérieur aux chiffres nationaux avec +
2,9 pour cent d'augmentation du nombre
de demandeurs d'emplois de catégorie a
en ce sont des personnes n'ayant exercé
aucune activité le mois précédent donc
dans ce cas là le mois d'août ce qui
porte le chiffre à 50 3900 dans le
département enfin l'insee à découper la
france en zone d'emploi et figurez-vous
que aux dents donc qui se trouvent dans
les yvelines est une zone de plein
emploi c'est une bonne nouvelle au
milieu de ces chiffres plutôt morose des
chiffres qui pourraient bien se dégrader
avec l'annoncé de plans de licenciements
comme récemment chez alcatel lucent sur
le site de vélizy pour finir avec
l'emploi cette opération de job dating
qui se tenait à l'espace saint quentin
il ya quelques jours à l'occasion du
mois de com du commerce on regarde
ensemble ce reportage
pendant le mois du commerce plusieurs
forums de l'emploi sont organisées dans
les centres commerciaux des yvelines est
l'initiative de pôle emploi comme ici à
l'espace saint quentin neuf entreprises
du territoire allant de la banque à la
garde d'enfants accueil des demandeurs
d'emploi pour des rencontres informelles
c'est moins stressant et puis ils se
déplacent dans un lieu qui est un autre
lieu que pôle emploi ils rencontrèrent
cote en direct et je pense que même
s'ils sont pas recrutés il rencontre
des gens qu'ils en font toujours font
pas c'est quand même une partie de leur
expérience sur l'entretien donne des
conseils aussi cv lettre de motivation
entretien tous les conseils sont bons à
prendre un premier contact pour
décrocher ensuite un vrai rendez vous
c'est une première approche donc on
regarde juste le cv on voit déjà
l'expérience
on approfondira plus par la suite en
rendez vous individuels comme vous avez
déjà ya déjà des rendez-vous qui ont été
pris oui on en a deux déjà qu'ils ont
été pris et une maman également qu'ils
étaient intéressés par nos services
c'est très bien organisé qui contient un
souci on à pôle emploi qui étaient là
pour pouvoir diriger et nous conseiller
aussi c'est super c'est bien tout ce
forum mais il y en a pas assez en fête
ses 50 ans
l'an dernier l'opération comptait 18
entreprises réparties sur l'espace saint
quentin et skywest ce qui avait permis
de réaliser une cinquantaine dans gauche
voilà et puis pour clôturer complètement
cette page et que je voulais c'est
pratiquement la fin gérard jouault ce
parce que vous me disiez en regardant ce
reportage que nous recherche du monde et
vous ne trouvez pas à les lancer votre
appel vous avez qu'un second a
effectivement nous le cherchons à
travers pôle emploi effectivement dû du
personnel porteur du personnel marbrier
effectué nous avons beaucoup de ballons
trouvé mon appart et l'appel est lancé
voilà merci à vous entendre merci à dix
pour homicides éclairage économique
merci à nos invités ce 7,8 est
maintenant terminé merci de votre
attention prochain rendez vous de
l'information au local c est demain
vendredi pour le 7-8 week-end a très
vite